como cualquier otro año en las playas de
copacabana e ipanema en río de janeiro
estaban llenas el domingo cuando el
hemisferio sur comienza el verano esto
ocurre en un país con la segunda cifra
de muertos por kobe 19 más alta del
mundo brasil registró más de 25.000
nuevos casos y más de 400 muertes el
domingo cerca de 186 mil personas han
muerto desde que comenzó la pandemia en
medio de esto el gobierno lanzó una
campaña la semana pasada para generar
conciencia sobre la vacunación pero el
presidente quien insistentemente ha
dicho que se trata sólo de una pequeña
gripa tiene una visión diferente de la
pandemia realmente está llegando a su
fin las cifras lo demuestran ahora
tenemos un pequeño aumento lo que ellos
llaman un pequeño resurgimiento que es
previsible pero la prisa por la vacuna
no se justifica porque afecta a la vida
de las personas no se justifica porque
se teme que las personas ven oculares
bolsonaro ha dicho que las dosis eran
gratuitas pero no obligatorias
insistiendo en que él no se vacunará
incluso cuando el supremo tribunal de
brasil decidió que las autoridades
locales pueden hacer de la vacunación un
requisito el presidente de extrema
derecha criticó al laboratorio facer por
solicitar una exención de
responsabilidad por las posibles
contraindicaciones burlándose de que la
vacuna de facer variante podría
convertir a la gente en un cocodrilo o
el súper humanos
fischer astrazéneca jansen y la china
sinovac están esperando la aprobación de
las autoridades de brasil el gobierno
aspira a comenzar la vacunación masiva
en febrero